[Kelly] I've got Blake Shelton with me
and in New York via
Skype is Cynthia Nixon!
(cheering and applause)
Blake, is it fair to say that
you shared a drink or maybe 13
with like everyone in country music?
[Blake] Yes.
- Okay.
- Yes.
- So, just wanted to make sure.
Well there's one drink
Blake may have skipped.
I was talking with Little Big Town the
other day and they had this to say:
Jimmy, wine beer whiskey,
Thomas Rhett,
University of Alabama
football coach, Nick Saban.
And what the hell, we'll just keep Shelton
'cause people like him here.
[Thomas] and I would say wine with Blake
because that would be
the least obvious choice
and I think it would be hilarious
trying to have a refined
wine conversation.
(laughter)
- That's awesome.
- The paper cuts would be fun.
- I love that, I realized they were right.
So I need to drink wine with
Blake, which brings us here.
Joining us now is the
founder of SommSelect,
and one of 300 masters
sommeliers in the world.
Please welcome in Ian Cauble.
What's up Ian?
[Ian] What's up everybody,
thanks for having me.
- Nice to see you again.
So how much experience,
Ian, do you have teaching
beer, whiskey, and, vodka
drinking country boys about wine?
- Very little, actually,
but I think Blake's a pro and
he's a great test subject.
So, I think he'll be successful.
- Blake and I have wine here,
and Cynthia has the
same wines in New York.
Are you all set, Cynthia?
[Cynthia] I am, I definitely am.
- All right. All right.
Well what will we be tasting, Ian?
- So today we're focused on
Burgundy, my favorite region
of the world, and this
is pretty much mecca
for great Pinot Noir du Chardonnay.
So let's start with this first wine.
So we have a John Mark
PO premiere Cru coming
from Chassagne Montrachet,
very famous village.
This is kind of like a fairy
tale for people who love wine.
So let's go ahead and
smell the first wine first and foremost
let's go ahead and grab the--nice
glasses by the way, Kelly.
- Hey, I don't know if you know
but we won an Emmy, so
we're upping our game.
- Fancy.
So first and foremost, let's
go ahead and grab the wine
by the stem.
You don't want to get the
wine warm with your hand.
If you're at a party and
you're holding the glass
by the stem or by the
bulb you're basically
gonna warm your glass pretty quickly.
Nice work, Cynthia.
- Yeah, Blake is looking good.
- So lets go ahead and
put the glass on the table
- You're not getting any,
if you hold your glass
but like this at a party
cause people will know-
- You're not getting any! (laughing)
- Yeah, you know what I
mean? It's like, loser!
(all laughing)
You're gonna want to
put the base of the stem
right here, at the base of
your nose here. A little bit.
What are you smelling, Blake?
- Why, what do you mean?
(audience and Kelly laughing)
- Are you smelling any white or peaches?
- Oh yeah it is kinda fruit, right? Fruit?
- Can I taste it?
- Yeah, lets taste it.
- Okay!
- We'll taste about a half ounce
and then I want you to
swirl it around your palette
for about five or six seconds
and expose all your taste buds
to it, swallow it without your nose.
You should be getting a
lot of information going
to your brain about all
the different fruits.
- Oh! It's like collecting in my cheeks
and the insides of my cheeks.
It's nice, like a little party.
- Exactly and you're
getting a lot of acidity
and freshness and this minerality.
Is anybody tasting a lot of
this like mineral component?
Almost like like oyster shell maybe?
- That's what I was gonna
say yeah, mineral component.
That's what I was going to.
I was going to leave with that.
It's weird that you did
first, but I'll just
let you talk about it.
- So this region used to exist
under a shallow ocean for
about 200 million years.
So all of the seashells
decompose creating limestone.
So what you're tasting
on the pallet is actually 185
million years in the making.
If that makes it taste any better.
- Bad snails.
- (laughing)
- What in the hell?
- Oh my gosh, that's actually
awesome that information!
- We can go back to bourbon
if you want Blake, It's fine.
- Oh, I like bourbon too.
I like--I like this.
- I like this too.
- This is actually the
first thing I've done
on this show, that's worth a crap.
Drinking. Drinking, finally.
(laughing)
- This next one is a pinot
one and Ian, you know that's my favorite.
- I do know that.
So this is coming from the
next village, just south.
This is called Santana coming
from a 120 year old vine.
So you can imagine that these great
vines have roots that are
going down almost as far
as a 10 story building.
What does everyone smell?
- Oh!
- This is going to sound
weird, but like leather.
I don't know why I don't--
- You know, I totally agree with you.
It smells like leather.
- Like, like aged leather,
like a really nice leather
jacket that I want to drink.
- He's known for having more earthy tones
and so you're getting it, for me,
you're getting this strawberry blossom
almost strawberry
preserves, but there's a lot
of secondary characters
of like leather mushroom
a little bit of like crushed rocks accents
of a little bit of baking
spices of vanilla from--
- Yea, because I was going to say that too
but I'll let you say it first though.
That was cool.
- That's my favorite.
- And this is a really young wine
and this wine is truly
gonna reach its peak
in about 10 to 15 years.
- I just want to give a shout
out cause I know that Christine
and our audience, I
noticed she had some wine.
She sippin wine with us today y'all.
Get it Christina! Yes!
Okay. Well, let's try vodka
cause I wanted to try it.
- Yes.
- This is Blake's vodka.
Everybody's got some, we've
got them a little tiny
little cute, adorable
little mini solo cups.
So let's smell it first.
Here we go.
What notes do you get,
Ian, from Blake's vodka?
- Well, I thought y'all might
of poured water in there.
- No!
- That's real.
- I am authentic, bro.
- We're drinking the real deal.
- Okay, wait. Let's taste--
- You know what? I'll say this.
The best vodkas in the
world don't have much aroma.
The greatest vodkas are very clean
and I was actually sipping
on this before the show
and it's really good. It's very elegant.
- (laughing) My man!
You know exactly what
you're talking about.
- It's no joke, this is really
good. It's really smooth.
And you know, good job.
- Okay, cheers.
- I'm going to send you
a case of it Cynthia.
- Please do.
- I haven't had a shot in a while.
- Did she really do it?
- Yes!
- Oh my god.
You have to fill more of these today?
- It's just one shot, mama's fine.
I smell hints of regret twenties
and someone holding my hair.
- (laughing)
- That's what I'm tasting
as well, poor decisions;
that's what I smell.
That's what I taste.
Congrats Blake, Master Somm
has approved your vodka.
That's amazing.
- Thank you!
(kelly and audience cheering)